Brigitta was supposed to save overwatch
now goes before a Jackson we might just
see Jo Wow that curse wind this one out
and advance to the grand finals just
doing my pipe
she was designed to bring something
different to the game innovation new
tactics a fresh approach instead she
destroyed overwatch Merc eat it was too
powerful there's just too much there I
want to know who's lizard thought it was
a good idea to release a hero like this
they will just simply swap it away
crucial time lost here for the outlaws
you want your team to win right they're
gonna have to play what's better by the
end of the first season of the overage
league people were getting pretty sick
of the games only solid strategy died
Janus kind of holed up here all they
need to do is push people back there's a
graviton surge can they finish out the
members of New York
rocket so Sega they come back and now
New York looks like they're finally
ready to end this attack run it's not
like I don't want to play overwatch
because I do but the meta right now
literally is ass I would rather do
push-ups I would rather lose weight I
would rather run a mile things like that
those are some things I'd rather do than
play overwatch right now in this meta
because it is boring as f the same thing
was playing out in every single match
over and over again the fans demanded
something new and Blizzard listened so
let's talk about Brigitta from a
gameplay standpoint because I think
that's where she really shines so she is
a support character first and foremost
but she also shares a lot of traits that
fit the tank role so it should be a
really interesting hybrid sort of
character that you want to play but
remember primarily she's support
Brigitta was designed to destroy dive
the utility she brings her stuns and
bashes makes her good at controlling
dive Hera's such as game G and Tracy she
was tanky had great crowd control and
offered your squishy healers and damage
dealers even better support than they
already had and one team in particular
took advantage of her powers fahza just
paid on in specs shortly after Brigitta
was released and unknown team shook up
the North American open division with a
new strategy that dominated the bracket
that team was called goats
of the fair actually winning this one
out just what's out of play all alone as
the almost about those get them in the
end now goes before age accents we might
just see Joe wow that curse wind this
one out and advance to the grand finals
goats rolled up to their matches with
three tanks and three supports which
sounded ridiculous at a time but they
proved that it actually worked
point of the comp is to have a high
sustain high mobility and compa it's
really hard to kill a big part of that
is heal output of bring goats proved so
effective that other team started
playing it to run away who later became
the Vancouver Titans used goats to enter
the scene with a bang in season two and
while there was a little bit of
variation in which heroes you pick
eventually the three three comp was used
by pretty much every pro team in the
world all of a sudden some random
amateur teams troll strategy was the
defining meta of overwatch and Brigida
was the whole reason that goats worked
she could heal her entire team provide
armor and deal damage she could do it
all and it was becoming a huge problem
just her base stats with her healing and
her alt and everything and her kid is
just extremely strong and it shuts down
a lot of the dps characters that used to
be played and allow for the more
traditional as we know like goats or 33
counts there's just too much there AOA
healing armor the armor buff reducing
damage stun you get your own barrier as
well I mean it's just the issue with
with how things went when you start
leaning away from mechanical demands in
terms of aim and that sort of thing and
you start leaning towards abilities is
that everybody that gets abilities one
of the biggest problems with goats is
that it essentially pushed damage out of
the meta for me it was more like oh no
we're gonna see actual damage dealers
you know damage players get shifted over
to Brigitta or you know profit that had
to play Brigitta for example you know
you're not gonna get you're not going
there's no they're not going to have
that role but Geeta was too powerful
casual will overwatch players love
damage Europe
they love flashy plays and high-skill
ceilings fine a little bit on his own
here all but he takes black work out as
he comes in but a goats comp with its
team fight winning Ultimates an
unstoppable sustain stomped on any
standard to damage to tank to support
comp every time and in this new meta the
players who dedicated themselves to DPS
heroes were becoming obsolete and so
you're gonna have guys like you know to
be Gatti to QT like all these these out
these like pure damage dealer guys
they're just gonna fall off because
you're you're going to instead lean into
the guys who can play the may you know
who can play those kinds of multi multi
role heroes that get lumped into damage
and then all of a sudden well there you
are you're not gonna see the damage to
us you're gonna see the mates and nobody
wants to see the pace as much as people
hate a dive it was a high speed high
skill meta Goats was boring I cannot
imagine what it's like to be a pro
player right now cha-cha-cha I want you
to think of this okay pro players scrim
this man up probably six to eight hours
a day think about it think about how
their brain chat this is your brain on
Gus
the games were drawn out confusing and
really boring to watch which of course
meant that fans began to hate the
character who brought them goats in the
first place I want to know who would
Blizzard thought it was a good idea to
release a hero like this she makes me
want to uninstall the [ __ ] game
Bridget has to be without a doubt the
worst hero edition in overwatch so far
if there is a masters high masters /gm
Brigitta on the other team and you're a
professional level overwatch League
tracer player you're probably gonna swap
or else you're kind of throwing and you
could dodge all the stuns in the world
by the reheater but the nature of it is
just by that Brigitta
existing her passive armor that she
gives via her heal her passive aura
health how tanky she is just the threat
and the nuisance that she can zone you
out she counters you just by existing
the hate even reached Benitez voice
active
mattel this medius I wasn't really
looking for support I wasn't really
looking for anything I was just kind of
fed up with that those messages popping
up all the time and I don't understand
why people like hashtag delete break on
my pictures or or call me fat as far as
the community was concerned
Perdita was a brain-dead character
capable of being played by any monkey
with a mouse and keyboard this is what I
mean dude this is brick
Patrick is brick and Africa spongebob
unlike this only two peoples from dude
blink blink blink blink blink oh my god
oh my god oh my god and then brick is
like this [ __ ] dude
let's go Blizzard spent months trying to
nerf Brigitta and tweak other heroes so
that people would stop playing goats but
nothing worked
eventually the devs just threw their
hands up and in a desperate bid to make
sure that goat was never played again
they introduced the tutu to roll walk I
think it's gonna be fun and these can be
exciting for sure
I imagine we'll see like a lot more dive
like winsome diva you'll probably see
they come back I like tracer and Ginji
allots because you just can't really
play a pig as much I get to play DPS
again whoo and though some people were
excited for it at first
roll walk ended up being pretty
unpopular - dude the metas dog [ __ ] I
don't wanna play it Mike okay look we're
gonna go play overwatch you're gonna
play approximately one game per hour
what do you even do one game per hour
and it's double shield Sigma I think
like one to two - can I definitely
killed it for me the queue times are
like hours long
I couldn't can play it I hear I want it
sometimes like everything just sucked
about it what's killing the game for me
right now what's what's stopping me from
being happy waking up and streaming
games and overwatch is basically I know
I'm not gonna be able to play my DPS I
can't play my DPS anymore it's gone no
one wants to watch a good streamer
whether you're really [ __ ] good at
the game or a former pro or pro if you
can't find a game of two hours no one's
gonna do that and in 2020 overwatch
League made the jump from twitch to
YouTube taking an even bigger viewership
hit in the process there's also a big
change that mostly just gonna die
completely
and when I mean dit I mean 50k viewers
and so when you're not on Twitch all of
us you're gonna lose that click-through
traffic of just people kind of who are
idling or doing something else working
you know and then all sudden it's like
oh you know it's like it's not quite the
same thing with YouTube it's harder to
find the channel you're not just gonna
you know click into YouTube I don't even
know like there's people that stream on
YouTube I never see him so when you're
not on Twitch it's going to be you're
choosing a much more difficult path in
terms of viewership numbers but with
overwatch 2 on the horizon and blizzards
continued willingness to try new things
there might be some light at the end of
the tunnel
yeah it looks grim right now but a year
from now who knows right and Blizzard
are certainly capable of turning it
around so no I I mean I I have not I
have not given up hope on them Brigitta
was supposed to fix overwatch she was
supposed to shake things up and get
people excited about the game again
instead she created the worst meta in
the game's history and nearly destroyed
the entire scene thanks for watching if
you want more content like this hit the
sub button and ring that notification
bell for unique bite-sized videos you
won't find anywhere else hit up our
Instagram Twitter and Facebook pages